l'intervention de la police et la tour
eiffel la police est intervenue ce soir
pour permettre aux techniciens de tdf de
commencer les travaux d'installation de
la cinquième chaîne sur la tour est
faite ce matin la ville de paris avait
interdite aux techniciens de
télédiffusion de france de monter sur la
tour ville de paris invoquaient les
travaux de sécurité nécessaires ladite
installation de la cinquième chaîne
reportage d' hervé brusini d'abord on a
vu apparaître trois hommes et une boîte
à outils ils et elles sont de
télédiffusion de france
leur but accédez au troisième étage de
la tour pour y commencer les travaux
d'installation des émetteurs de la
simple mais pas question d'abord il va
falloir négocier
il ya là un commissaire des policiers en
civil on passe des coups de fil et
pendant ce temps derrière cette fenêtre
on palabre côté tdf on exhibe la
servitude préfectoral qui doit laisser
l'accès libre aux techniciens côté
mairie de paris on invoque les mesures
de sécurité nécessaires à une telle
installation
df se compose d'un planté 3 tonne et
demie de matériel
trois tonnes et demie matériel placé en
4e étage de la tour eiffel suppose à
l'évidence un certain nombre de
précautions que je suis leur devoir de
prendre parce que je le rappelle est je
le rappelle si à un accident quelconque
le responsable c'est moi dans ce
fantastique la sécurité les conditions
de sécurité et la politique comme
incident mon problème n'est pas de
blocus et de politiques pour l'instant
en la matière j'ai une responsabilité
j'ai une chercher le bâtiment 1 sur le
bâtiment précisément voici que
réapparaît
la boîte à outils alors la situation est
débloquée
les travaux vont pouvoir peut-être
commencer weeds et escaliers sera vive
nous feront monter ça a été le fruit de
la négociation cet après midi oui on
peut le dire à présent sous bonne garde
les émetteurs de la 5 devrait être en
place avant le fait payer il en ce qui
concerne la tour eiffel aujourd'hui elle
avait un peu la tête à l'envers
précision l'interlocuteur david de paris
était monsieur rocher